you give tips in the book on how uh
single women should
hook up at a wedding now is that
something that
and i guess that's something some women
think about right they're at a wedding
it's the thoughts in the air maybe some
guys too
yeah i mean i think that guys at
weddings have a pretty easy get laid
gimmick which is uh you know the flower
girl
if you can secure her to dance on your
feet women will be like oh my god he
wants to be a daddy
but it doesn't work that way for women
like if i danced with a ring bearer
people like oh jamie has such a little
dance partner like they would never
be like wow she looks like wife material
because it doesn't work that way
yeah so in the book we talk about
different um different
tips and one of them for me i think is
like you know
uh like a bridesmaid maybe two
bridesmaids dance together so it
instills in the guy's mind like ooh
three-way you know what i mean like it
gets a little spicy or maybe like a
bridesmaid
dances with a grandpa to show that you
know she's into older guys
and the reason that works is because
then her her
potential catch could feel boyish in
comparison and feel the need to
demonstrate that he too
has the uh classic american masculinity
of a world war ii vet
you know um do all women put this much
thought into it i put a lot of thought
into it
yeah okay um another one that's really
fun it's a little extreme but bear with
me it's just like
fake a choking you know what i mean like
fake that you're choking or
fake a fainting right next to a
groomsman and then he'll be like oh my
god i have to save her.
and you're not a damsel in distress
you're just a woman with an agenda
i think you've helped a lot of people
with disappearances i really do think
you've helped people